what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have a brand new look at
spider-man no way home an awesome look
with doc ock and spider-man this was
released just this morning not too long
ago and it is by empire magazine the
full entire article for spider-man is
coming out tomorrow so this week and
next week expect a lot of spider-man no
way home news of course when i'm trying
to be on vacation visiting family but no
worries i'll still be covering
everything you need to know about
spider-man no way home and today we
actually have some pretty big
confirmations about ant-man 3. got a
tiny spider-man no way home trailer
update for you today of course plus
we've had a lot of spider-man no way
home plot leaks and if you've taken a
look at all of them you might have
noticed that all of them that seem to be
coming from somewhat legitimate sources
all seem to have a common theme and that
common theme is a particular scene
involving a death and the empire
magazine article has actually been
leaked ahead of time which i'm not going
to talk about until tomorrow when it
comes out because they paid to have that
exclusive however there is one point
that i would like to mention in this
video so if you're loving marvel and
spiderman no way home be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
also we are giving away a spider-man
action figure a bring variance arts
figure it's super awesome and all you
have to do to enter subscribe to my
channel and the channel cosmic culture
and leave some comments on some videos
okay so first things first we have to
talk about this amazing photo that was
just released this photo may remind you
of spider-man 2 as doc has spider-man
caught with his robotic tentacles he's
actually only using two tentacles here
one to wrap up his body and the other to
hold his head now luckily spider-man has
on the iron spider suit however i'm
pretty sure doc ock is going to tear
that apart now we actually know that
spider-man is going to have multiple
suits during this movie one of them is
going to be a magically enchanted suit
and perhaps one of the reasons that he
gets a new upgraded suit is that doc ock
tears his iron spider one apart which
means that doc ock and the other
villains could actually arrive pretty
early on in the movie the spell is
probably going to be done way early into
the first act which means the villains
could probably pop up pretty early as
well now this is a sick shot but check
out what is written down below in the
right hand corner i believe this is
coming from director john watts it's a
quote that says spider-man no way home
isn't just a sequel it's a massive meta
multiverse outing in which peter parker
finds himself fighting iconic villains
from past lives as its creator tells us
this is nothing less than spider-man end
game okay um the fact that they're
calling this spider-man end game gives
me the chills but no they didn't come
out and say that toby and andrew are in
the film but to me this kind of says it
they literally say it's a meta
multiverse outing in which peter finds
himself fighting iconic villains from
past lives how are you going to pull off
mentioning past lives if you don't
explore those past lives and obviously
our tom hollands peter parker does not
have past lives but the others do he's
literally talking about spider-man's
past lives tom holland does not have
past lives but toby maguire does and
andrew garfield does as well there is
literally no other meaning to peter
parker's past lives than toby and andrew
the films that came before him the past
films to me this is pretty much all the
confirmation that i need now we just
wait on that second trailer and hope
that sony and marvel give us a little
tiny tease of the other two spider-man
now we have more spider-man news but
first let's talk about something truly
epic
bill murray has officially joined the
mcu it is confirmed now there was a
report about this i think maybe a couple
of weeks ago from the cosmiccircus.com
they said they noticed that bill
murray's name had been on a cast list
for ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
now of course until somebody at marvel
studios or someone from the cast
confirms this themselves it's just a
rumor however yesterday it seems like
bill murray confirmed it himself he was
in an interview not about the marvel
movie that he is going to be in but an
interview where he did say that he
recently filmed a marvel film the
interview was with a german newspaper
and the interviewer patrick heidmann
posted on twitter some of the details he
asked bill murray is it especially
important for you to work with people
you know well and like in which bill
murray replied with this you know i made
a marvel movie recently i'm probably not
allowed to tell you but whatever anyway
some people were pretty surprised why i
decided on a project like this of all
things but for me the situation was
completely clear i got to know the
director and really liked him he was
witty humble everything you want from a
director and with the cheerleader movie
bring it on he had already made a film
years ago which i think is dang good so
i agreed even though as an actor i'm not
normally interested in these huge comic
book movies so there you have it bill
murray confirms he filmed a marvel movie
and for those of you who may be curious
as to what that movie is it is ant-man
3. ant-man and the wasp quantomania as i
mentioned in the beginning and that is
actually confirmed in this article as
peyton reed was the one who directed
bring it on and is now directing quantum
mania so huge confirmation for the mcu
and ant-man 3 right now and we also have
another pretty big confirmation again
one that some people probably already
guessed by now but it's good to have a
confirmation in a recent interview
jonathan major spoke out and he
mentioned that he who remains will not
be in ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
it is going to be kang and there is a
difference a big difference now again we
already knew this and again loki made it
pretty clear that he who remains was a
very different version than a lot of his
variants he even said if you think i'm
evil wait till you see my variance if
you think i'm
evil
well
just wait
until you meet my
variants of course during loki he did
also mention that he has been called a
conqueror so at one point in time he
could have been the person known as king
the conqueror but of course there are
going to be multiple different variants
of king as well but the most important
part to note is that kang the conker is
probably one of the most brutal versions
of he who remains and that is the
confirmation that we are getting from
jonathan major stating in ant-man and
the wasp quantomania we are going to get
a pretty mild and calm he who remains
but we are going to be getting a
destructive kang one who wants to
conquer now we have a lot of spider-man
no way home news today but of course i
would not leave you without news about
that trailer this is an interesting
story in a recent tweet from the
official twitter account with great
power which is a book that is about the
story of live-action spider-man one of
the writers sean o'connell tweeted from
there talking about the trailer he said
a lot of people somehow missed my point
there's a high probability that you will
get a second morbius trailer before you
get that anticipated spider-man no way
home trailer whether you want it or not
now this should be taken as a rumor
right now because even sean himself says
there's a high probability it is not
confirmed however the marketing has been
so weird and different for spider-man
far from home i would not be surprised
in the slightest if this is indeed true
it seems like sony does have some type
of a plan for their own spider-man
universe even though their spider-man
kind of isn't in it right now who knows
maybe their plan is dependent upon
spider-man no way home so if the morbius
trailer does drop sometime soon be on
the lookout for that spider-man noah
home trailer and of course i'll update
you as well now as i mentioned we have
two other big things to talk about one
is that empire magazine article which
i'll talk about last and the other one
is about what some plot leaks are saying
there's a major death scene according to
these and it's with somebody that you
are definitely not going to want to see
die however if this is true i can kind
of see what it's going to be setting up
for the future of spider-man now of
course these are not confirmed to be
true yet they are just rumors but in
case they are true i am issuing a
spoiler alert if this does indeed come
true it's a pretty big scene so many
reports and plot leaks posted on reddit
have some things in common and one scene
that they have in common is aunt may
dying in case this is true i won't say
much about the scene however i will say
that i could understand why this would
happen because rumor has it that at the
end of spider-man no way home dr
strange's spell finally works and
everybody and i mean everybody forgets
that peter is spider-man now this may
sound extreme but fans have actually
been complaining for a pretty long time
now that we haven't seen spider-man on
his own he's always had help he's always
had some type of a mentor he's had tony
stark now he has doctor strange and of
course the other two spider-men this was
kind of upsetting for some people
because we want to see peter on his own
taking on all of these challenges by
himself having to step up well if in the
next spider-man mae is gone and nobody
knows who he is he is definitely going
to get that chance seems a bit extreme
but we'll have to wait and see now last
but not least even though we did get
this picture from empire today some
parts of the magazine did leak and
although they didn't come out and say
hey toby mcguire and andrew garfield are
in this movie they do reference the sam
raimi universe and the web universe
stating that the villains come from this
universe and if the villains come from
this universe then we can imagine that
some heroes come from that universe as
well again the full article comes out
tomorrow and i'll be doing a full
coverage of that in the meantime let me
know what you think about this brand new
picture of doc ock holding spider-man in
the comments down below and also let me
know what you think about this possible
death of aunt may leave your thoughts
down below don't forget to like this
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you